picture of the commanding general the
legendary 82nd airborne division will go
down in history he was the last american
to leave afghanistan's main airport
yesterday ending the u.s military
mission that began after 9 11. this
morning the taliban control that airport
and the fate of dozens of american
citizens still in afghanistan is
uncertain charlie daggett is in qatar
the new home of the u.s embassy that was
forced to evacuate
good morning well this is the u.s air
base where the last mass evacuation
flights landed also some of the last
american troops to arrive late last
night pretty much leaving at the stroke
of midnight in kabul handing the country
back to an enemy they spent 20 years
fighting
defensive flares lit up the sky as some
of the last american c-17s flew out of
kabul for good
moments later the nighttime fireworks
display came from tracer fire a
celebratory taliban gunfire rang out
across the capitol
the last american soldier to leave major
general christopher donahue
by morning light the taliban made clear
the country was under new management
strolling through the airport posing
with some of the disabled military
equipment left behind the flights have
stopped stranding an unknown number of
afghans who wanted to flee taliban rule
some of those lucky enough to escape
wound up here at the aludaid air base in
doha in two weeks hangars were
transformed into holding areas for 55
000 afghan refugees
it doesn't matter what country you go to
you just need to go yes
america's longest war came to an end
with a chaotic calamitous mass
evacuation and a suicide bombing from
isis k that cost the lives of 13 u.s
service members and 170 afghan citizens
remaining americans and afghans holding
special visas will either have to pack
buses for the border wait for the
airport to reopen or hunker down they
have little more left now than hope the
taliban make good on their promise they
won't be prevented from leaving
and hope that america still holds any
influence over an enemy it was unable to
defeat a new chapter of america's
engagement with afghanistan has begun
the military mission is over a new
diplomatic mission has begun
physically that diplomatic mission now
moves here the u.s embassy will be
operating on a doha cutter it is a major
regional u.s ally and has also served as
a go-between with the taliban a role
that is only going to become more
important in the future
for cbs this morning charlie dagetta
doha cutter